tu sais le plus dur c'est les
journalistes qui en parlent parce que
oui mais ça c'est le plus dur parce que
comme il va être pas un rond ils ont
peur de perdre leur place
alors bonsoir bon tu es peintre cinéaste
acteur écrivain tu as des maîtres de ce
qu'on ne pourra appeler le
touche-à-toutisme non pas vraiment je
suis d'ordre beaucoup tu dors beaucoup
et comme il faut survivre quand on se
réveille en gros je fais tout ce que je
peux ouais je rame mais tu fais bien
alors on va pas faire toute ta carrière
parce qu'on serait là jusqu'à 3h du
matin enfin il y a la Planète Sauvage tu
es bien ah oui c'était très bien il y a
le locataire chimérique qui a été adapté
par paulanski au cinéma on a laissé
tomber le chimérique parce que les gens
comprendraient pas mais qu'est-ce que tu
penses de l'adaptation de Polanski parce
que il a adapté ils ont 12 ans plus tard
et c'est un film c'est jamais un livre
mais je l'aime beaucoup et je l'aime
beaucoup comme acteur or à l'époque je
me rappelle que les gens mettent
dubitatif
que je préfère alors par contre on va
passer à des succès après en mais là on
va parler d'un bide c'est la galette du
Roi Lion pour comment tu as fait ça mais
c'est parce qu'on a essayé d'aller dans
le sens du public c'est quand même une
tentation
on se dit après tous les ramassés
on n'est pas plus
compte mais ça marche pas ça marche pas
quand tu sors un bouquin chez Seguy qui
s'appelle les combles parisiens
illustrations
après dans les textes c'est quoi c'est
des souvenirs par exemple j'aime
beaucoup les anecdotes et alors il y a
un film qui s'appelle marquis alors
c'est la dernière année de Saad à la
Bastille c'est ça et puis il a des
rapports comme ça avec son son sexe qui
s'appelle Colin et c'est des êtres
humains mais avec des masques d'animaux
sont des hybrides mi-hommes mi-animaux
un peu comme dans un roman comme dans la
fontaine comme de dans le je sais plus
quoi
mais Colin le sexe de marquis lui est
humain et comment tu arrives chez un
producteur tu dis voilà c'est l'histoire
du marc il est à la baisse un chien il
parle à son sexe et les gens te filent
de l'argent pour faire ça oui parce que
tu as écrit en général depuis un certain
temps le scénario quand tu écris il y a
pas d'argent
et tu trouves des gens assez fous pour
mettre de l'argent à être tu trouves à
distributeur et des acteurs assez fous
pour jouer vraiment ils étaient aveugles
ils tombaient dans les pommes parce
qu'il respirait tout dans les masques il
respirait trop de gaz carbonique tu
trouves un distributeur assez fou pour
être de l'argent tu trouves des exploits
comme ça là c'est fou tu sais le plus
dur c'est les journalistes qui en
parlent mais la preuve parce que oui
mais ça c'est le plus dur parce que
comme il va être pas un rond ils ont
peur de perdre leur place
mais nous on l'a perdu lui c'est pas
pour notre public mais qu'est-ce qu'on
peut dire là-dessus
parce que Béatrice Dalle c'est de voir
les mondes merveilleux des stars pour le
cinéma c'est le nom de la regarder ça or
ce cinéma il existe plus je vais te
demander un truc parce que tu as dit
l'image de la vie dans les livres pour
enfants parce que je pense à télécharger
il est retransmis son sexe sans merde et
qu'est-ce que tu penses des crados mais
moi je pense qu'ils vont tout piqué
mais je trouve que c'est ce qui est
amusant c'est l'énervement de
l'épiscopat français et espagnol c'est à
Rabat qui m'a dit d'Espagne il m'a dit
mais en Espagne tu sais
tous les prêtres sont très très énervés
par les crados j'ai beaucoup de gens
énervés par les crados mais enfin ils
sont pas encore condamnés il y a pas
encore de contrat non tu sais que tu es
le client idéal pour ce qu'on a inventé
dans cette émission qui s'appelle l'anti
portrait chinois
[Musique]
tu serais une maladie
mais encore que le Paris reste ouvert et
j'ai toujours pensé qu'il y avait une
façon de faire la sécurité sociale à la
carte on parie sur de quoi on aura et si
on gagne on est remboursé le triple le
loto c'est facile ça peut rapporter gros
le cancer donc
le cancer
donc non mais il y en a d'autres actions
de voiture étant une troisième donc tu
parierais tu payerais en fonction de ce
que tu as décidé plus ou moins cher et
les autres seront remboursés moi je
trouve que c'est un truc qui est
intéressant et si tu étais un microbe
c'était un petit microbe un petit
microbe un tout petit microbe un
champignon une truffe
un vice city avis la masturbation c'est
tellement bien c'est ce que tu préfères
c'est ce qui reste quand tout le monde
s'en va
tu t'étais une guerre une guerre non un
mouvement un mouvement un moment
guerrier ou un truc la révolte du ghetto
darsovie je trouve assez exaltant le
seul truc chaque fois que les civils
cassent la gueule aux militaire
oui oui mais cela dit ça n'a rien à voir
c'est simplement que j'aime pas trop les
militaires un accident
un accident
[Musique]
très bonne réponse une cicatrice
non je dirais pas Heidelberg
vous voulez la voir
alors
elles sont là toutes elles sont toutes
là mais fesses tout
enfin
et si tu étais un terroriste pour finir
passé un terrorisme
pas du tout non je ne vois pas comme un
[Musique]
chevalier
la mienne est fraîche maintenant
[Musique]
et mettez un pouce bleu